[Musique]
on se posterre au plus profond de son
compte à Jésus tu fais des merveilles à
chaque instant mais quelle est la
merveil aujourd'hui que je peux partager
avec mes
amis merci
Marie ton amour pour nous merci
Marie car tu prends soin de nous merci
Marie
t d' vige
Marie nous te prion
être enfant veilleur c'est B c'est prier
tous ensemble et et pour pour des
intentions particulières euh on a un
diocèse chacun pour prier pour prier
particulièrement pour ce desè là quand
on est chez nous et et c'est super parce
qu'on danse et on chante et parfois on
mange des gâteaux moi je remercie Dieu
pour pour l'amour qui nte et pour cette
bonne année qui commence je voudis
remercier le Seigneur pour les bonnes
résolutions qu'il' don moi je remercie
le Seigneur pour la grâce qu'il m'a
faite et pour la force qu'il m'a donné
de répondre à son appel et pour la joie
qu'il met chaque jour dans mon cœur moi
je remercie le Seigneur pour la mort qu'
nous apporte et pour certains l'aide
aussi qui peut nous
[Musique]
appor mais en tout cas ma joie c'est de
voir ses enfants vraiment grandir dans
le bonheur dans la joie et de donner le
meilleur d'eux-même parce qu'ils sont
vraiment conscients que ils ont la
chance d'être chrétiens il y a même un
qui se prépare au baptême et il a dit là
il a dit tout à l'heure je remerci le
Seigneur de m'avoir donné la grâce de
prendre une bonne résolution c'est
lui-même qui choisit de de voilà de ce
de et ça c'était de demander le baptême
voilà oui et quand il a commencé à être
enfant en vailleur le désir n'était pas
là et voir quand j'ai posé la question
mais qui est enfant veilleur il a dit
mais moi je suis pas baptisé et c'est
lui-même qui a fait le choix et là il
vient de me dire que j'ai encore une
année de préparation et il est vraiment
on voit hein c'est vraiment une fleur
qui s'ouvre il est épanoui ça donne
envie de prier pour d'autres enfants euh
parce que dans le monde il y a des
séismes et tout au de plein de
catastrophes et il y a il y a souvent
des personnes qui peuvent pas prier
alors du coup nous ça nous donne envie
et
et et ça
donne des raisons à d'autres personnes
de de de diocèse de prier pour
euh de prier pour d'autres enfants c'est
c'est bien ça ça ça met du B au cœur
enfin on est joyeux quoi quand on prie
pour d'autres enfants
voilà ça donne aussi un peu envie de
voyager à travers le monde oui et euh
d'aller les voir ces enfants qui ne
peuvent peut-être pas connaître
Dieu tu pris pour les enfant d'où euh de
jongo je crois au Rwanda Rwanda c'est où
le Rwanda
euh je crois que c'est en Afrique oui et
plus précisément tu au centre j'ai eu la
grande joie de rencontrer sœur Marie
Ange l'année dernière au chînet et nous
avons organisé à l'école Saint-Anne la
rencontre de sœ Marie Ange avec les
enfants pour justement qu'il deviennent
enfant veilleur moi j'avais été très
surprise quelques jours avant notre
rencontre j'avais dit discuter avec les
enfants du thème de la prière
et beaucoup beaucoup m'ont dit prier
très régulièrement donc bien évidemment
je pouvais pas faire autrement que que
que l'on se retrouve régulièrement ici
donc c'est Madame Le Mercier qui nous a
proposé et donc on y est allé et tu as
trouvé ça bien voilà et après tu es
revenu et tu fais ça depuis combien de
temps 2 ans et tu pries pour les enfants
de de Venezuela le Venezuela à comibas
ah c'est où ça comme BIM si c'est ça
c'est bah on une mais là bah après à la
maison B on dit trois Je vous salue
Marie pour pour le Dieu pour les enfants
h tous les jours tous les jours c'était
normal qu'on priait pour des enfants
parce qu'il nous renvoyit l'ascenseur en
même temps c'està-dire bah qui qu'il y
avait des enfants qui prier pour nous
alors nous on priait pour eux c'est et
ça et ça nous fait du bien bah oui c'est
bah ça nous rend plus fort de savoir
qu'on prie pour nous et voilà qu'est-ce
que tu fais quand tu pries à la maison B
soit je me mets devant la crèche mais
quand il y a pas de crèche je me mets en
haut dans le silence un genou devant mon
icône du Père du Fils du
Saint-Esprit Seigneur Jésus n te confi
Pauline Adrien et Arthur et tous les
malades dans le monde conf les enfants
du Pakistan et du Venezuela
[Musique]
Je vous salue Marie pleine de grâce le
Seigneur est avec vous vous êtes bénie
entre toutes les femmes et Jésus le
fruit de vos entrailles est béni sainte
Marie Mère de Dieu priez pour nous
pauvres pécheurs maintenant et à l'heure
de notre
mort Père du Fils et du Saint-Esprit
[Musique]
AMEN